Republican senator James Lankford of
Oklahoma is a member of the Senate
Intelligence Committee and the Homeland
Security and Governmental Affairs
Committee he joins us from Capitol Hill
for an interview you'll only see on CBS
this morning
senator good morning good morning to you
senator I want to get your reaction to
something President Trump has said and
something President Putin also agrees
with which is that the investigations in
America of Russian interference of which
you are a part on the Intelligence
Committee have gotten in the way of
Russia US relations what do you think of
that assessment I think they are in the
way but I think it's not the fault of
the United States they're in the way
Russia has tried to interfere in our
elections just like they've interviewed
in elections in Ukraine and much of
Europe so this is something that Russia
pulls on itself so if if Russia wants to
say that there's a problem in the United
States and Russia it's certainly not the
United States fall for that it's Russia
the president looks at that and says
well we're all to blame meaning about
the United States and the Russians well
I would disagree with that I would say
that there are individuals that
obviously want to be able to bring up
issues here and try to be able to divide
us as two countries but Russia clearly
their human rights violations what
they've done in Syria attacking
hospitals what they've done in invading
Ukraine Crimea the nation of Georgia you
assassinate ends into the UK clearly
this is a Russia that doesn't have the
same values that that we have and if
there's a division it's because we
absolutely do not understand the
Russians and how they behave and how
they mistreat humanity of whether it be
freedom of the press open free
independent courts they are completely
dissimilar to us is it normal for a u.s.
president to even consider the idea of
turning over a u.s. civil servant in
this case a former Russian ambassador
Michael McFaul
to a u.s. adversary like Russia is that
normal I don't know if that's normal I
would say I'm adamantly opposed to that
and I don't know of a case in the past
on that through all the history of it
but there's no way I would turn over a
former diplomat
to Russia's for investigation and for
conversation on that they're acting
their official duties we need to
continue to be able to stand by our
folks do you think President Trump is in
some way compromised by Vladimir Putin
no I don't think so at all I've seen no
evidence of that and we've gone through
extensive work in the Senate
intelligence community to be able to go
through a lot of evidence
and a bipartisan way I don't think it
was a compromise there I think he does
treat the president of China and the
president of Russia a little different
than he treats any other world leader
that would that be for economics or just
the complexity of the relationship I
don't know but those two he does treat
different than others but I don't think
there's any compromise in that
relationship speaking of his treatment
senator you on the Intelligence
Committee have had a good close eye and
on the work done by the US intelligence
agencies you've also had a close eye on
what the Russians have been up to I
wanted to get your valuation of what the
president said in Helsinki he said
referring to both Vladimir Putin and the
US intelligence agencies I have
confidence in both parties given your
experience looking at both parties do
you have confidence in both parties I
have absolute confidence in what is
happening in the US intelligence
agencies and what they're doing and how
they're trying to be able to do it they
work very hard to protect the privacy of
Americans but be very aggressive about
trying to pick up information about our
adversaries any attacks they may have
coming towards us so I by far trust more
our US intelligence agencies are you
frustrated with the verbal gymnastics
that we've seen the last couple of days
where would means wouldn't no means no
more questions as opposed to the answer
to a question what are you thinking
about this whole tone that we're
watching as it all plays out for the
last couple of days well it is obviously
odd to be able to watch as we walk
through this for the last several days
on it but I would say I watch actions as
I do more than words on anything when I
know what's happening with the part of
homeland security here and what they're
doing to protect our election systems
what's happening in the intelligence
community and what they're doing in our
systems that's extremely important our
DHS has been by far more prepared for
the 2018 than what they were for the
2016 elections security clearances in
each state trying to be able to work
through the process to protect the
elections we have sanctions on the
Internet research agency that's a
Russian group that tried to interfere in
our social media I would certainly hope
the administration would put sanctions
on all those entities that were involved
from the most recent indictment so
that's how are you feeling about the
actions that's good you're watching the
actions how are you feeling about the
actions of the president over the last
couple of days does anything concern you
I think the president's not careful in
his words in the way that he actually
talked about things but that's no grand
shock that
been true all the way through the
election time period in the campaign all
the way to president now that he's not
careful in how he says things and that
sometimes gets misunderstood and when
you're the president United States
everyone watches every single word and
how you say it which is important
because it does affect the world senator
Lankford Graham to leave it there thank
you you bet thank you